bonjour michel rapeau merci de répondre
à nos questions vous connaissez bien le
proche orient vous êtes entre autres
l'auteur du livre tempête sur le grand
moyen-orient aux éditions ellipses le
précédent scrutin avait abouti sur un
pacte entre benyamin netanyahou et son
rival centriste benny gantz
à quelle alliance s'attendre cette fois
à un pacte avec guéi rapide avec naftali
bennett a écouté les paris sont ouverts
parce que apparemment c'est la casse et
c'est lé quatrième élection au très très
peu de temps via une cinquième monsieur
netanyahou est très optimiste qui dit
toujours qu'il a gagné en fait il
s'avère qu'il n'a pas tellement gagner
puisqu'il est un capucin incapable
probablement assez probablement de vue
de former un gouvernement
alors je sais pas je ne sais pas non
c'est vrai que c'est un paysage qui est
un petit peu contrasté contradictoires
mais aussi d'ailleurs mais c'est dans la
nature de tous les hommes politiques de
tous les pays du monde de crier à la
victoire
son décès est en réalité dont il n'a pas
gagné mais c'est cette nouvelle
coalition qui se dessine
elle sera plus fragile plus solide que
la précédente
en fait en d'autres termes la question
c'est celle ci si ça ne tient pas est-ce
qu'on va vers des 5e et élections
législatives en deux ans où on a un peu
plus de deux ans écoutez motion en t2
j'avais à parier
ça se passe sur la victoire ou tel ou
tel parti c'est sur la butte
il veut la tenue de 5e d'élections parce
qu'il n'y a pas de raison que la
situation n'a pas changé
fondamentalement la question des
alliances quelques questions pendantes
par ailleurs je peux en parler beaucoup
dix ans de gueule d'un parti à l'un des
partis arabes donc sur lesquels ne
compte pas monsieur natanyahou lycée
concurrents d'ailleurs enfin qui pouvait
empêcher en cas une alliance la loire
d'aller par timidité et on disait qu'il
n'avait peut-être pas atteint le seuil
parti d'avoir des députés
90 etc s'il était sûr le point d'obtenir
je ne sais pas ce qu'il en est
aujourd'hui l'enfant tout cas ça on peut
pas reprocher quelque chose quelque
chose qu'on ne peut pas chez à la
démocratie parlementaire et électorale
ttc du suspense et d'animer la scène
politique
alors pourquoi
vous parlez de suspense vous pariez sur
des cinquièmes élections législatives
prochainement on a entendu un talent
dans le sujet d'amaya soubelet le
discours de benyamin nétanyahou ils
appellent à un gouvernement stable mais
force est de constater que la vie
politique israélienne est tout sauf
stable que traduit cette instabilité
politique et comment arrêter cette
instabilité politique est-ce que des
cinquièmes législatif ça pourra le faire
des sixième et septième
c'est quoi la fin lors vous avez bien de
produire les questions comme ça je crois
que finalement le problème c'est qu'il
n'ya pas vraiment l'alternance puisque
les disons les deux blocs principaux
exactement la même politique qui ne
résolvent pas les problèmes fondamentaux
qu'israël donc finalement globalement
que ce soit monsieur natanyahou son
concurrent ou vice versa on n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance
ça changera tout jury il se croire entre
toulon vainqueur victorieux vis les
examens ils attendront la prochaine
élection en les électeurs peut-être en
ont marre j'ai l'impression que le taux
de électorale le taux de participation
dépend très très bruyante minuad 68 39
j'entendais % m'enfin bon la france n'a
pas de leçons à donner il a globalement
je pense que c'est assez préoccupant une
démocratie quand même très formel c'est
un jeu de parti politique puisqu'un jeu
démocratique que les problèmes
fondamentaux sont pas réglés et que le
problème de la population arabe
steijns avait cependant finalement je
crois que le coc vite d'ailleurs n'a pas
rangé dalcin la gestion de la pandémie
gérer les affaires de monsieur netanyahu
sape à québec un opus raéliens ont filmé
une intense campagne de vaccination un
as à oui mais on se demande si la
campagne de vaccination d'abord faire
doubler la pandémie comme peut arriver
dans certains autres endroits parce que
les vaccins
c'est vrai c'est pas tout ça ici les 6
et les vaccins qui savent pas
grand-chose en israël cherche pas les
qualités utilisera en tout cas vraiment
il ya un problème et les israéliens
n'ont peut-être marre d'être aussi pour
revenir sur la situation politique
d'israël
selon vous comment se fait-il que les
deux blocs pro et anti netanyahu ne
parviennent pas à se départager
parce qu'ils payent piétine ils sont sur
la même en fait ils sont sur la même
clientèle électorale
de change et qu'on marque trois unités
sont personnes natanyahou est au pouvoir
depuis longtemps et puis bon on connaît
bien ses concurrents ont les codes les
pommes on peut les deux factions ils
sont connus mais on communie n'ont pas
de programme vraiment vraiment très très
différents c'est pas très séduisant
comme comme alternative quand on propose
la même chose que l'adil nader serti
plus ou moins et gagnent sans gagner
perdre sans perdre et c'est donc c'est
un peu décourageant
c'est caricatural un peu de la
démocratie parlementaire dans ces
conditions mais je crois encore une fois
je pense qu'il ya des problèmes des
citoyens israéliens en théorie qui n'ont
pas qu'ils sont pas considérés vraiment
comme des citoyens à part entière
je parle donc des israéliens arabes je
ne permets pas les palestiniens traités
comme du bétail mais des israéliens
arabes
on voit encore que leur parti bon
finalement de se sont tenues pour compte
comme du beurre puisque je pense que
d'avant ce monsieur netanyahu a dit
qu'il voulait pas une majorité qui
compterait sur des parties ceci ou cela
notamment sur les parties arabes
donc c'est réglé donc évidemment les
arabes palestiniens n'ont pas voix au
chapitre entre nous s'il l'on voit c'est
tout à fait théorique
je crois que c'est ça mais bon pour
l'instant après on attend la cinquième
l'élection qui va pas tarder à onex
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
michel raimbault je rappelle que vous
êtes un ancien ambassadeur de france